alright folks it seems like we have a
quorum of people in the room I know
there's a lot of missing people but as
long as everyone stays on mute we'll be
in good situations so before we get
started I just want to make sure
everyone's aware of a few things
we are coming virtually for the third
month in a row the idea of this talk is
to us be a Smackdown between gnomes one
of the most viewed videos we've ever had
if no I'm talking about gams
and now Gavin's coming here to trounce
know'm is the goal here so we'll see if
that happens
no pressure Gavin to to knock this out
of the park
yeah thanks jarred absolutely notice no
Mustaine muted for this
[Laughter]
so everyone part of the beautiful thing
about part of the thing about this
pandemic while we're not able to meet a
person we were able to get speakers from
other parts of the world which is nice
we have Gavin coming to us from
somewhere very west and north of here
and we last month we had someone from
California the month before someone from
New York but you know we have New York
people too so gonna do our best to keep
people coming in from all over to help
facilitate this being a little different
than normal we have a slack team if you
go to NY hacker org and then click on
the slack link and if you're doing it
from mobile you might need to scroll
through the menu a little bit but as my
hacker org slash slack that HTML in fact
we could post that link in the chat
there is a slack team all devoted to the
meetup in there we have you know
channels you could talk about this
particular Meetup there's an AR help
this Python help get help there's events
in general there's job postings so a lot
of you who are regulars at the meetup
and you come to the physical meetups you
know that I like to start the meet up by
saying who's hiring well we can't do
that here because there's no way we
could all facilitate this 100 some
people virtually so if you have a job
and you're looking to hire someone
please go into the slack team to the job
postings channel and post your job on
there I just saw a volunteer opportunity
posted today a job posted a few days ago
go posted in there I know lots of people
have gotten employment start from the
Meetup so hope that we can still get
employment through this virtual meetup I
know that someone just very recently
posted a job let me go check out what
job it was I'll shout it out
let's see lambda literary org post a job
does Kevin Troy before that georgette -
Hermann a long term member she posted a
looks like a contract job at georgette
posted one before that metadata posted a
job
let's see some people are looking for a
full-time employment Doctors Without
Borders posted a job the US Military
Academy posted a job the health recovery
solutions as you see there's lots of
jobs there so if you have a job you're
looking to hire post it in here if
you're looking for a job to get hired go
in there and see what you could do about
finding a job so that's the first thing
I hear someone so yeah I try to keep the
questions to slack make a little easier
also for my regulars y'all know we like
to start with pizza we always have pizza
beginning in the meet up well keeping
the tradition alive today
I got revolta so you see here it's a
Neapolitan style it's a wood-burning
oven you could tell from the back of it
has good cheese lock but it also came
delivery so it takes a while so it's a
little cold but it's gonna be very good
I firmly believe this is one of the best
pizza places in the world I I will say
that firmly I I'm gonna go that bold but
when I was in Naples someone told me
this guy owned a pizza shop told me his
friend owns the number one pizza shop in
New York and he said revolta
I'm like I agree with you so as we all
know we like to keep is very social it's
hard to ask questions here so if you can
ask your questions in slack we have a
channel called I believe it's called
meet up now uh May I don't think we have
the channel if you go to the events
channel and I if you go into the events
channel and ask your questions in there
I will collate all them and I'll ask
Gavin afterwards at the end of the
meetup I'll ask everyone's questions for
them so please go ahead and
look for that someone did actually ask
in the group chat here what's the
workspace name on slack it's NY hack are
just like our group name and I will go
post that link in the in the zoom chat
right now everyone gives me a second
so in the zoom chat I am posting the
link it's my hacker org slash slack that
HTML and those here this giant photo of
JD long taking a selfie at the
conference above him there is a link to
join slack go on there to join the
conversation and Amada the real a model
there's a June 22 media channel now
within great so I won't actually ask the
questions in the June 22 meetup Channel
please go in there ask the questions so
it's easy for me to find many of you
know we like being very social here as
I've mentioned a few times since we
can't be in person if we all go back
together at the bottom toward the bottom
of the room there is a virtual bar now
whether you have an alcoholic beverage
or a non-alcoholic beverage or whatever
you want you go to that bar area after
the talk we'll be hanging out down there
just to chat and hang out I myself will
have like a bottle of beer down there
but feel free to have a bottle soda
bottle of order or actually no bottles
use tap because it's better so feel free
to go do that to the bar afterwards I've
already showed you the website and my
hack our I think so we've put a lot of
work on that's built with our so there's
if you go to NY hacker org there are 10
years worth of presentations maybe even
11 years worth now and about five or six
years worth of videos so there's a lot
of information you can get there lastly
well two more last least next month we
don't have planned yet but will almost
certainly be virtual
it is likely going to be talked about
Linux actually believe it or not then in
August as part of our week they will be
drink we're still working on the details
on that actually I'm not certain but it
should be miles McBaine talking about
Drake
and speaking of our week August 2012
through 15th next in August will be the
virtual in New York our conference we've
held this thing in person for five years
this will be our first year virtual I
know out of people here no miss I think
no I'm scheduled to speak I don't want
to promise that I think he is but I'm
not sure we have David Robinson we've
angel gummin we have the both no Lass's
we have Emily Robinson we have Brooke oh
man I've just had a blank in her name
sorry Brooke over there we have Dan but
there you go thank you we have Dan Chen
we have a holt max kun we have a whole
great crew of people speaking if you
want to hear more about that you go to
our stats dot ai I'll put that in the
chat our stats dot a I that's how you
find more about the conference we try to
make it as cheap as possible since it's
going virtual try to you know make it
just cover costs and but if you want to
be even cheaper the code and why hack
our get you 20% off all members of this
Meetup are eligible anything we do
basically the code NY hack our get you
20% discount so go to our stats that AI
to see more about the conference with
all of that I had gone through all of my
notes we gots a bit of a late start
because we had a hitch with the the
gather platform we are gonna get started
so remember folks please try to hang out
the bar afterwards remember about the
conference remember about next month
remember about jobs and remember that
this talk is now a challenge for Gavin
to be the best gam speaker we've ever
had so coming all the way from
Saskatchewan that way that's right
Saskatchewan that's right yeah yeah all
the way from Saskatchewan please welcome
Gavin to the stage thank you very much
and thank you Jared for inviting me
thank you known for suggesting me and
linking me with Jared just want to check
can everybody hear me okay cool thank
you
right I'll get on in slide share my
slides
okay hopefully everybody can see there
so um yep my name is Gavin Gavin Simpson
I I am I'm not Canadian I moved to
Saskatchewan to Regina in Saskatchewan
I'm about six seven years ago now I'm an
ecologist and paleo ecologist this just
happened to get into I'm doing
statistics over the last sort of since I
finished my PhD you really what I'm
going to talk about today is how is what
I do at games and that's sort of
learning when things have changed in the
environment where they've changed and by
how much have they changed and I'm
interested in in things that how
ecosystems change in time and in space
and as well see some there are some
reasons why I've ended up using using
gums to look at these kinds of data the
dirt that I come across and I'm going to
go through some of the kinds of data
that I work with on a sort of day to day
basis okay so just very generally I mean
we're doing statistics to try and learn
from data in the presence of noise we
have these noisy complex data sets and
we want to learn something from those
things so we're going to learn from data
we do that using music using the models
and we might estimate parameters from
some theoretical model that we might
have so in my field we might have a
population model like a lotka-volterra
model or something like that where we're
interested in estimating parameters for
some population to see whether the
population might crash and die or
whether it's going to explode we might
have some theory and we want to compare
that with some observations so you might
want to estimate some parameters from
your model compare those with the
theoretical expectations and then often
we want to make progress where there's
Larry little or no proto theory and we
might just want to estimate things from
our data and that's something because
data is really good tells us things
about the world and we want to learn
from that even if we don't have a very
good handle on what the was actually
happening in in the world
so when we're learning from data it
could be something as simple as just
fitting a linear regression like this or
it could be some fancy deep neural
network as trained on massive data sets
and you know we could meet we might like
prefer this depending on your
sensibilities or you might prefer this
kind of thing but learning involves
trade-off we can have some models that
have potentially low bias or we can have
models that have low variance so we have
models that fit the data really well
have low bias but they might have high
variance and all we can have models that
perhaps the simpler and therefore they
have lower variance but they might not
fit the data as well and that
essentially reflects this this continuum
from the deep learning model and to the
regression model the simple linear
regression and there's another trade-off
here often if we have models are simple
models like the linear regression it
might not fit the data very well but
it's really interpretable I can
summarize that linear coefficient at
that linear line and a single number and
that tells me how much Y changes as I
change X but for something like some
very is some deep learning model it it
might be I know people are working on or
making these things better but often
they can seem like a black box and they
might fit the data really well but it's
it's much harder to understand what that
model is is doing and how its encoding
information and so we do have these
trade-offs when we're learning learning
from data so here's a slide of stolen
from nomes gam course and caroms kind of
sit in the middle if you're gonna think
of linear models on the one hand of
being a sort of simple end of the model
spectrum and then some black box sort of
machine learning tools of the other end
then gams kind of fit in the middle
there they're very interpretable and
generally as long as we don't start
fitting very high order functions and
the the methods actually try and stop us
from doing that to some extent but so we
but we can fit things that are much more
complicated than linear models so we can
do better at fitting the data but we
also get out some easily visual
visualizable function
that mean it's easier to understand what
the model is encoding how its encoding
information so games work by fitting
Wiggly functions Wiggly things and this
is kind of what gams are doing here I'm
showing a foursome covariates and put it
to variable X I'm just showing ranges of
different functions and these are I'll
explain in a minute how these things are
created and but this is just a spline
and it's just showing the whole
potential range of models that might
show how the effect on our response our
function f of X ho that has a response
changes as some smooth function of our
covariance and so we're going to try and
use these kind of Wiggly thing as these
kind of smooth terms these splines in
our models rather than just assuming
that everything is strictly linear or
linear in parameters that we can
estimate from some linear model so let's
have a look at what gams are and and how
we how we fit them so contrary to
Jarrod's protestations gams are not
magical and the next few minutes I want
to try and explain how gams fit data how
do they learn from data and there's a
lot of these gams when they were first
invented they you had to plug in a lot
of things you had to tell it what the
what kind of degrees of freedom you
would like for your your model so you
had to choose your complexity or friend
well I'm not talking right I kind of
gone today I'm talking about gallon gams
that we can fit using mg CV and other
software tools where you don't have to
specify how many degrees of freedom you
want to fit your model with you can just
let the model itself to choose how
Wiggly these functions should be but
they're still not magical and I'm going
to explain how they work and they work
basically through something called a
basis expansion and so here's an example
this is one of the examples that got me
interested in using gams for for
modeling time series data so at the time
I'm showing that here the Hadley Center
data from the met office in the UK
this is just their this I'm showing
actually is the median value of a large
number of ensemble runs where they have
some big model that pulls together all
of the temperature information that
they've collected from all over the
world and then turns it into these is
the median estimate of the global
temperature or annual temperature from
about 1852 in this case I can't exactly
remember when I got it to a bit to some
some date up here I think this is
up-to-date so it's like 2020 2016 I
think anyway this is the latest run that
I was looking at and what we might want
to do here is we won't want to estimate
what okay there's a lots of wiggling on
going on in here but we might want to
fit the sort of average change in
temperature and we might not want to
just fit a straight line through these
because that suggests that temperatures
will have been changing at the same rate
everywhere and clearly from this graph
they haven't been and when I started
looking at some of these things that I
was looking at the literature on how
people have approached this and the
classical way that people would approach
fitting some sort of smooth model to
this would be to use a filter or some
moving average of course when you do
that because of the you're using some
width of window you end up not being
able to fit the most recent values
because you haven't observed the values
that are inside the window that extend
into the future and so there was a lot
of papers being published by Michael
Mann and and and lots of other people
about how best to to pad the data to
essentially make up new data that we
haven't observed yet so that they gave
you an unbiased estimate of what the
trend was at the end of this time series
and of course I'd started to come across
scams and I thought what games would be
a much better way of trying to do this
because you don't have to sort of you
don't have this argument now about how
to path the data do you pad it by just
extending the last data point do you pad
it by extending the sort of mean of the
time series so there was a lot of work
going on how to how to do that padding
basically making up data and I thought
gammas could do that better and I'm
going to illustrate how Graham's work
using this particular time series so one
basis expansion that we could use would
be just to sort of fit Pauline oil
so we could fit year plus your squared
plus y cubed and so on this gets really
difficult partly because we we have to
then choose what degree of polynomial we
might want to fit and and that's not
necessarily that easy to do and also you
can see the problem that we're getting
that once we start to get into this sort
of Lights at these two purple curves
here they seem to be doing a pretty good
job of fitting the data in this in this
time series but they do very poorly they
start to do weird things at the ends of
the time series so they start shooting
off in and doing weird things and this
is a well known problem with these kinds
of polynomial models but the polynomial
that I just talked about having X and
then x squared next cubed that is a
basis expansion and it's actually quite
similar to how you and gams uses just
don't use that basis expansion that was
giving us all those problems so the
basis expansions that gowns use splines
I showed you an example of a spline a
few minutes ago and splines they're
formed from these little basis functions
so if we this is our range of our Cobb
area X just between 0 & 1 and I'm just
showing one kind of spline here this is
called a cubic spline so it's a it's
kind of made up of little chunks that
splines can be made up of little chunks
of cubic polynomials that are made to
join up at what are known as these knots
these locations here certain knots so we
have some knots some places that we want
to have these piecewise cubic functions
spread over and how we create the spline
is by creating what I'm showing on this
screen here at the moment which are
these little basis functions so each one
of these is a cubic basis function it's
it has some positive value its highest
positive value at it's not so there's a
knot here there's a knot here and so on
okay and and then they these this
particular basis has this other property
that they're 0 at every other knot so
you can see this particular basis
function sort of wiggling around but
it's 0 at every other knot
so we've changed from having X or X plus
x squared plus X cubed and so on we take
X and we turn it into these little basis
functions so here I might be turning it
into ten basis functions so instead of
just having X in my model I have ten ten
little basis functions that represent
the effect of X and then what I want to
do is just choose some different weights
so the figure that I showed you earlier
with the the black line the wiggly black
buying it was being generated just by
choosing some different weights for each
of those basis functions so each one of
those lines has a different weight for
the sets of basis functions and that
gives us these different splines and our
job now is to find some weights or model
coefficients that allow us to have a
spline that fits the data really well so
I hope what spline what coefficients do
we can we get to fit the data so here's
a another quick example this is just
some classic training data that we use
in the gums to illustrate how splines
work I've just sampled some data the
true function is shown in the golden
color on here and then the data that
I've sampled from it as shown in the
grey dots I know what we're going to do
is going to do the same thing so I'm
going to put little basis functions in
here ten of them and then I'm going to
choose some weights that will make this
fitted spline go as close to the data as
we possibly can with ten basis functions
so this is this animation is just going
to repeat in a second this is just
showing how the spline fits the data so
we choose different weights those
weights for these coefficients are low
the spline to fit the data best
so our model fitting when we're fitting
our model what we're trying to do is
we're trying to find the best values for
some coefficients so that makes us blind
go as close to the data as possible and
we do that we find our coefficients by
maximizing a penalized log likelihood
function in general but this is all the
splines doing so really our problem
comes down to just trying to find
weights for each of those basis
functions
and it's exactly the same as almost
exactly the same as the polynomial model
that I showed you earlier where we were
you we were finding the coefficients in
the linear model to make the polynomial
fit the data best no we're just doing it
but we're just using a different kind of
basis expansion to make it fit the data
well but we don't want to over fit the
data so we need to try and avoid
overfitting we could use as many basis
functions as we had observations here
and then we would fit the data perfectly
but we just be interpolating everything
and we'd have a horribly Wiggly function
so we need something to stop as
overfitting and we the thing that stops
as overfitting is something called a wig
leanness penalty we don't want to fit
too complex a model or too Wiggly a
model so we have a penalty the Pennell
and i'll tell you exactly how the
penalty is measured in a second
but we just have something that controls
how much how much of a penalty we
actually pay for the complexity so when
we have a very strong penalty then we're
essentially fitting a straight line
through so the plot on the top left here
is showing what we'd have if we have a
very strong penalty and we're penalizing
very strongly against we cleanest and so
we just go back to a straight line okay
we can't do any better than the straight
line we can't penalize back to a flat
function and I might talk about that or
it might come up in questions later why
we can't do that
but that's the bet sort of worst we can
do and as we start to relax the penalty
we start to have to see more and more
curvature our spline gets a bit more
Wiggly and we start to fit the data
better but if we were up to overfit if
we were to choose a penalty that was too
small then we had all of all these sort
of little Wiggles that we see here in
this fitted model they're just
overfitting the data they're just
fitting the noise rather than the signal
and then this one here is pretty close
to the optimal actually for these
particular data but here we just see
that we've got some but some were paying
some penalty we're not paying as much
penalty as the top left here but we're
not allowing it to be too Wiggly and so
our model fitting really comes down to
finding some balance between this at one
extreme and then something that's really
Wiggly at the over
so that lambda is called the smoothness
parameter and that's the thing that gets
optimized in in the model whilst we're
choosing our coefficients or estimating
our coefficients our weights for our
basis functions the lambda is the thing
that's controlling how much of a penalty
we pay so how do we measure the whig
leanness though at these curves so that
we can work out how much the penalty is
costing us okay
well I said I was going to try and avoid
some math and do it in pictures but I'm
gonna do a little bit of math what I'm
showing you here is this is a measure
this is we cleanest and show in two
different ways and Bill this is just
saying we're going to integrate over the
second derivative of our curve so we're
actually set paying a penalty for the
curvature of the fitted spline that's
what the penalty is that some measure of
wiggliness now you can have different
ones in here the default in mg CV and
the default one in in most sort of gam
like software is to do a penalty on the
second derivative on the curvature so
that just avoids having splines that fit
that the change direction too quickly
that's what it's measuring it's
measuring the curvature and so you pay a
really strong penalty if the spline is
going is wiggling backwards and forwards
too much okay so that penalty this bit
here this I'm writing it now in a
slightly different format here but
that's what goes into the model this is
the the penalty and it's measured in
terms of the model coefficients which is
really useful when we're fitting because
we don't have to do any of this stuff
okay so we have a penalty matrix which
is s so that it kind of encodes the
wiggliness of everything and then these
vectors of coefficients and together
that is a measure of the wiggliness so
once we've set up our penalty matrix
which is really easy to do instead of
those basis functions we can set up that
this sort of penalty matrix s then all
we need to do is estimate the
coefficients and then that tells us how
Wiggly our function is and then we can
pay the penalty for that so then this is
what we're actually fitting so in L this
is our log likelihood of our parameters
and then we just pay some penalty and
this is lambda this is our smoothness
parameter in here that's just telling us
how much penalty we're going to pay
for the wig leanness of our given curve
so now we're going to choose beaters and
our smoothness parameter that a lowers
to fit the data best without overfitting
because then we'd be paying if we were
overfitting we're going to be having two
Wiggly a function and therefore we will
be paying a price for that wiggling us
that complexity and therefore our
penalized likelihood log likelihood is
likely to be lower and therefore
indicating a lower thick so if we do
that in mg CV and I showed something
that was similar to this earlier but
this is the optimal fit to those
temperature data and we can do that by
just modeling our data straight away we
don't have to pad the data at the ends
you'll notice that the confidence
interval on here is getting a bit wider
at the ends and that's reflecting the
uncertainty lit work that we have
because there's nothing to constrain the
spline really beyond the data
so our uncertainty about where that
spline should go is is also reflected in
our model we don't have to do any
padding we get a nice fit and also I
mean this data set here is regularly
spaced in time but we don't have to have
data that irregularly spaced in time we
could have gaps in these time series and
the GAM would still work for that sort
of data
so cams are really quite useful for sort
of fitting data but this is a really
simple example and I wanted to get on to
explain a little bit more about how
we're using gams sort of that and the
real advance of the tools that M GCV
provides us so let's just see how we do
that fitting before we go on to do
something more complicated this is
enough to get you essentially the fit
that I showed on the model this looks
very similar to a GL M if you've ever
used the GLM function in you know we
just change a letter so now we have an a
cam instead of a GL m and we change one
of the thing in our in our formula
rather than just using the name of the
cove area as we would for linear terms
in a in a model we have to wrap it in
this function S and when you do that
then you by default you get a particular
kind of spline is called a thin plate
spline but you
can do cubic splines things such as the
examples that I showed earlier but this
will give you a spline with ten basis
functions and then there's only one
other thing that you have to do and
actually have to choose to fit using
method equals Remmel and this sort of
sets the model up in a particular way
and gives you the best behaving
smoothness selection it's not the
default unfortunately and that's why the
name mg CV that's where that comes from
the GCV used to use a thing called
generalized cross-validation and that's
the default but that can understand we
don't want to we it has a tendency to
under smooth and we'd rather not have
that happen so fitting using Remmel or
ml is something that you should
definitely be doing but this would set
up that model that I just showed on the
other on the page there so it's really
quite simple changes and then if you
wanted to you could use the family
argument if you're familiar with GL and
we could use the family argument to fit
like a Poisson model for count data or
gamma models for continuous positive
reals and so on so it works very much
just like the GLM function except we
have to tell it that we want smoothes in
our formulas and that we also have to
tell it we want to do smoothness
selection using rimmel but that's all
that the change in these objects that
gamm produces are actually very very
similar to the GLM objects they work
similar and they actually use some of
the GLM methods that come with our to
fit them alright sorry not to fit them
to for plotting them and looking at the
residuals and things like that
okay so I wanted to show a sort of a
more complicated example no that
illustrates some of the more advanced
features in M GCV and there's lots of
more complicated models that we can fit
we're not just limited to fitting single
time series so this is some of the work
that I do sort of on a day to day basis
I'm a I'm an ecologist but I'm an
aquatic ecologist I guess and I'm
interested in how Lake ecosystems change
for time and a lot of my work was done
using the recent past the last few
hundred years which we often looked at
using lake sediment
so the mud at the bottom of the lakes
but to understand how those lakes were
changing over the past couple of hundred
years we also want to know how the lakes
are changing today and so I do a lot of
work on limnology and things that change
that are going on in lakes the
contemporary like ecosystems today and
so this is an example of an example that
I've been working up to illustrate how
useful gans are in in non-standard
settings and the problem that we're
looking at is we've got a lot of data
now that records how do what the lake
temperatures are and people have been
interested in collecting temperature
data from lakes for a long time people
use their lakes for swimming and fishing
and all sorts of things and there's been
a long history of limnology stations
where on so field stations on lakes that
would go and measure the temperatures
regularly because there were people
permanently based there and so there's a
long history of data especially in
Europe for these kinds of these kinds of
data and know that we've got these long
records we want to know can we detect
changes in the legs that might be
related to climate change so on the plot
here and these are data that come from
yes Tim will weigh and colleagues and
estimate former PhD student of mine and
there's no doing really good things in
sort of modeling Lake structure
temperatures and things like that around
in in Europe and this is a site in the
UK in the UK Lake District so about half
way up the country before you get to
Scotland and it's a thing called Leyland
town and this has been studied for a
very long time by the freshwater
Biological Association and now the UK
government's centers for ecology and
hydrology and what we're seeing here is
a record of I think daily maybe or maybe
monthly temperatures I forget exactly
what the resolution is for this
particular site but we're seeing this
sort of very marked seasonal variation
in in the temperature of the water I
mean this farm it just it warms up
slowly and in the summer and then it
cools
over the winter but looking at this that
does seem to be some change in these
minimum temperatures how cool that the
lake gets in the in the winter we don't
really see that apart from perhaps this
early period here after 1960 we don't
really see much change in the maximum
values these Peaks are all at the same
value this roughly similar level but in
the minimum we are seeing changes
potentially and so we might be
interested in saying well how do these
annual minimum temperatures how are the
eight that a change over time why why do
we have to worry about this well at this
annual minimum temperature is a very
strong control on many lake ecosystem
processes we know that extreme events
where for example where we've had very
mild winters in Europe so that there are
very warm period in Europe in 2006-7 had
a very strong and long-lasting effect on
the lake ecology of some lakes that were
studied in in Europe so we know that
very mild winters extreme warm winters
can have long-lasting effects and there
are many and species there of ecological
importance and from conservation
importance that our cold adapted species
they if the legs become warmer then
there are fewer lakes around for these
cold adaptive species or refugio because
these species can't necessarily move
around now because they're being come
sort of stuck on the on the landscape
and there's to these examples of arctic
char and the opossum shrimp and there
are lots of other examples of these cold
adaptive species that are becoming
threatened no because of potentially
threatened because of climate change so
we didn't just have data from blunt on
those paper that yes them will wearing
colleagues put together they pulled some
of the really long records from European
fresh waters going back to the sort of
1960s or even earlier in some in some
links and so we've got quite a few lakes
and from UK from the UK we've got blown
town and estimate water and Windermere
is a big lake in the Lake District
that's
into the north and the south basin I
think fear is in is in Island Loch
Levinson Scotland and then we've got
batten which is in Sweden and then I not
exactly sure where where the sea is but
zero at sea is in in Austria yep
so we've got some lakes all over we've
got all showing similar patterns but we
want to know how are these minimum
temperatures changing over time so you
can't just and limnology Scyther a real
they really like just spinning linear
models of the sort of thing I showed you
very at the very beginning they really
like fitting linear models to these
kinds of data and so that's actually
what was done in the in the paper that I
mentioned when I talked about for a long
time but we we shouldn't really be doing
that extreme values these extreme
minimum temperatures don't really follow
or meet the assumptions of the linear
regression so the central limit theorem
applies to a large number of statistical
methods it it underlies the favor that
underlies a lot of the math and the
theory that allows us to turn our
coefficients into p-values and things
like that but it doesn't apply to things
like block many more or block maxima
these extreme events so these are the
annual minimum temperature and so this
is the sort of lowest temperature that
was recorded out of all of the
observations in each year and I'm they
just this is the data that we're
actually going to look at and there does
seem to be where that we've just changed
the data to be looking at these annual
values that does seem to be some trend
in these some lakes show more of a trend
than others so we're going to want our
model to adapt it to the patterns in
each of these individual lakes but all
of these lakes are sort of from roughly
the same part of the world so they
should all look roughly similar to them
talk to one another okay
so I mentioned these things called block
minima so these are block minima in the
statistical sense parlance and they are
the minimum value of a block of twelve
months worth of observations so they're
block minima they don't really follow
the sort of central limit theorem too
and apply to these kinds of data in the
same way but thankfully we do have some
theory to work on so there's this
theorem that says that the maximum of a
sample of iid random variables after
some renormalization can only converge
in distribution so it's a limit theory
to one of three possible distributions
one of them's the Gumbel distribution
one of them is the fresh a distribution
and then the other one is the Weibull
distribution and this theorem is known
after there people who sort of
independently came up with it and worked
on on it and I'm showing his a the the
free gentleman that came up with this
particular theory now I mentioned black
mimic minima and the theory just report
refers to block Maxima and we need to do
something to fix this you know does that
feel reapply to minima values in the
same way that applies to Maxima well we
can just apply a very highly technical
fix to our data we just negate them in
and turn them them into Maximo now we
can fit our model and as long as we take
account of the fact that we did this
this highly technical data manipulation
then we can a zombie account for that
afterwards then our model is fine for
fitting minima even though we're going
to use them as Maxima we just have to
remember that now we're looking for a
decrease in the Maxima which would have
been then means an increase in the
minimum temperatures okay so now we have
these three distributions how do we
choose between those three distributions
which one do we use because they all
actually have different properties and
it depends on on whether the events
become less and less how the events that
really long return periods it's just
what happens in the tails essentially is
what how these different distributions
differ from one another well thankfully
we don't actually have to fit or all
three distributions and then choose
between them we can fit a model using
something called with a generalized
extreme value distribution and this is
the generalized extreme value
distribution it's actually a
distribution that has three parameters
so it has a location parameter mu just
like the the mean in the Gaussian
it has a scale parameter segment just
like the standard deviation in the
Gaussian distribution but it also has a
shape parameter this squiggle here or Z
I think it's called and so you can by
plugging in different values for the
shape parameter you actually get back
the different distributions so when Z is
0 we get the Gumbel distribution when
it's greater than 0 we get the fresh it
and then of racheting and then when it's
less than 0 we get the Weibull
distribution and so now we can we have
this one distribution that we can use to
fit to the data and then we can sort of
understand what kind of distribution it
might be by looking at the estimated
values of the shape parameter so what we
want to do is when how the GAM is going
to fit these data and we're going to do
them all at once in a single model we
want to have the similar sorts of
patterns we're gonna have the similar
sorts of smooth trends in each of our
legs but we can clearly see there are
some non linear patterns I mean if we
look at fatten for example nothing which
seems to have happened in this
particular lake but then it starts to
increase after about 1990 2000 so we're
going to need things that are nonlinear
to tackle these ok so what I'm gonna do
is show how we can fit what we call a
hierarchical camp so it's hierarchical
in the sense that we have not just one
subject we have many subjects many lakes
that we want to fit and we're going to
use this generalized extreme value
distribution for their response so
that's what the H gamma H gams are these
hierarchical models and the LSS just
refers to location scale shape these
things might be better called
distributional gams
they're often called just gamma LSS
depending on the terminology or vector
gams all they mean is we're just going
to have a model for each of these
parameters normally when we're fitting a
linear regression or a GLM we're just
fitting the mean parameter mu and we
then estimate Sigma from what's left
over in the data ok but we it's just
treated as a constant each observation
has the same value every observation
might have a different meaning
because that's our model that's a line
or us flying everything had the same
value of Sigma
but with these location scale models we
can actually have linear predictors or
formulas for each of these parameters so
now I can say that the mean the variance
and the shape parameter are all going to
vary with smooths of year so they're all
going to have a smooth function of Year
in them and I'll show you how we
actually fit it and it sounds a lot more
complicated than it than it really is
but this is the kind of output that we
get these are the estimated smooth for
the mean function so they were we have
got nine nine lengths so there are nine
smooth functions here this is the
estimated sort of variance parameter or
standard deviation the sort of scale
parameter and this one has much less
variation except for one of our links
and then this is the value for the shape
parameter which controls sort of which
of those distributions there is really
we're just interested in mainly
interested in in this one at the moment
to sort of model the trend in them but
you could actually use these other
parameters to say things about how
likely it is that we would get a
particular temperature of any particular
temperature now and to see whether it's
become more or less likely and things
like that
so these taken together each of these
all three of these parameters define the
full distribution this notation that I'm
showing up here is just saying okay I've
got this is my my year
it's just centered here so I've just set
the zero value to be in the middle of
the time series and then I'm just saying
I want one of those for every Lake
mm-hmm and I'll show some of the fitted
values and things in a minute this is
this is how we use ng cv so it's a
little bit more complicated than the
example that I showed earlier rather
than having long formula because I've
got three parameters I want to estimate
I have to provide a list of formulas so
the first formula here this is the
standard ones is for their fitting the
mean and that's the only one that
contains the the response which is our
negated minima
we have a formula here then this is for
the for the scale parameter and then
this is a formula for the shape
parameter and in each case I've just got
the same smooth function so this is a
smooth function at that centered year
variable and then I'm also doing what's
known as a factor smooth interaction
here because I don't want just one
smooth for all legs I want to have a
different smooth that each like but I
want them all to be sort of roughly the
same and what this is doing is creating
essentially a random or not a ransom a
random slope and intercept kind of more
like a mixed effects kind of model but
it's doing it for a spline so instead of
getting a random linear function out for
each leg what we're getting here is a
random smooth for each like in word
getting that for this is the trend in
the mean this is the trend in the scale
parameter and this is the trend in the
shape parameter we have to tell it what
family will want and then there comes a
series of link functions for these
because we can have a link function for
every parameter and the link function is
just map the the values from these
linear predictors on to the right scale
and so because there's some restriction
on the shape parameter it's white needs
this law get scaled parameter but apart
from having an extra formula and a few
extra control things in here this model
can be fitted in exactly the same way
and it only takes a few seconds actually
we can mgc Peter to fit this so this is
what the observers fitted values look
like and for each of our sites we do a
pretty good job I mean obviously we're
not capturing a lot of the sort of
year-to-year variation that goes between
these sites and a and more and more
rigorous analysis would actually account
for some of that there might be some zod
a temporal autocorrelation or have you
in here and but we're doing a pretty
good job and actually if you look at the
residuals and all the rest of it that
doesn't seem to be an aryl to
correlation left in these residuals we
do seem to be a pretty good job of
fitting these values even though there
is still quite a bit of scatter between
them
as I know these are if you then undo
that highly technical fix this is what
the estimated trends are doing in each
of these in these legs and so we see the
sort of strongest changes perhaps in
vatten and we see these legs are and
perhaps a bit more sensitive because
they were sort of very much ice-covered
lakes for a large part of the year and I
know they're starting to sort of see
melting happening or not as many years
where we are seeing stronger ice cover
and that's why this the sort of water
temperature couldn't get any lower here
because it was frozen but no was sort of
seen these lows where this lake is not
freezing up now as often or as deep so
we have our model one model gets us our
nine fitted values it does a pretty good
job of fitting all of these things okay
and for summarize this if we actually
start take these models apart and look
at them then these minimum temperatures
have increased in the last sixty years
they've increased on the order between
one and three degrees and we can can
show and I am not showing it here for
interest of time but we can show that
the distributions of these minima have
also changed over time because we
modeled all of the parameters we can
actually look at the shapes of all those
distributions and this kind of has
implications for future events it means
it's really unlikely that we would see
temperatures as cold as we were seeing
in the 1960s no in any of these lakes
and that really means that these refugio
or the habitats for some of these spread
threatened species and they very much at
risk because of I guess climate warming
and so this is a pretty good way of
modeling news data it's actually very
simple we didn't have to learn very much
more except knowing that we needed this
particular family and we can fit this
using the same sort of tools that we
would have fitted to the temperature
data except we've just changed a few
little bits so I wanted to just show
that we don't have to be restricted to
just filling these things in mg CV and
used to be is a really great tool Simon
would and his students and postdocs over
the years have done a really good job of
making a piece of software that that
works really well it runs incredibly
quickly
but it is not perfect for everything and
I wanted to talk about BRMS as another
tool that we could use where we can
reuse some of the things that we've
learned from mgcp but apply them now in
a sort of fully Bayesian way and take
advantage of fitting using stem so mgc
beef it's what's known as an empirical
Bayesian models when we when we're
fitting with Remmel or ml smoothness the
models that mg CV fits when we we have
those particular smoothness things are
empirical Bayesian models there's a the
fever just coincides that a Bayesian
view is smoothing just happens to be
what you're doing when you're fitting mg
CV models with r ml or ml smoothness
they're empirical Bayes because we don't
have the full posterior distribution we
have to make some assumptions about that
but we do get these point estimates
which would be the posterior and
posterior means from a fully Bayesian
one we don't get the full posterior
though and they're part of the reason
for this is that it's an empirical Bayes
method also is that we have improper
Gaussian priors so and I should say we
can't penalize the linear bits of the
basis so they're improper price is an
improper kind of Bayesian analysis they
don't have proper priors on these things
but it is a Bayesian analysis if we
wanted to do fully Bayesian modeling
then we can use brms we can actually use
jugs and other things as well to do this
but I think BRMS are sort of the easiest
interface for learning and also uses
Stan which is sort of a very popular way
of fitting Bayesian models at the moment
and we also don't have to learn anything
new or we have to learn very little new
because we can specify our models using
smooth functions that mg CB provides the
only difference is that we can't use
tensor products these are created by the
TE or the TI function we can just use
tensor products that are created using
the t2 function and this is just because
of the way BRMS and it's the same with
the gam for package is that that uses
the LME for package to do the actual
fitting it's just because of how the GAM
model has to get represent
as a random effects mixed effects model
right but apart from that difference we
can pretty much you do everything that
we can do in mgcp we can do in ber ms so
this is actually just was research that
was been going on that I've been doing
with one of my colleagues and my
colleagues at the University of Regina
on microsystem and this paper actually
got published just on Friday it
microsystem is a liver toxin that's
produced by cyanobacteria these
blue-green algae that we might find in
our lakes and and ponds especially
during the summer months where there's
loss and there's lots of nutrients and
lots of and the temperatures are high
and these things can bloom and then the
cyanobacteria create these toxins
microsystem is one of those toxins and
they frequently cause problems for
humans and for pets they're often the
reason why there are lots of no swimming
signs up on on lakes in the summer
because these things have been detected
they probably won't kill humans but if
there's a very you know strong bloom
with lots of toxins being produced they
can certainly kill pets and they can
certainly make you feel very very sick
as a yourself
and so they sign a bacteria they bloom
under the right conditions they cause
things called HAP's harmful algal blooms
and we've been seeing increases in these
Habs all around the world because a lot
of our lakes have been polluted through
nutrients so things that are stuff that
we that goes down the surge pike things
that come off farmer's fields and so on
we're what wastewater treatment plants
are not very good and haven't been
removing some of these nutrients or
where agriculture has led to many
nutrients being a fertilizers applied to
the to the to the field or and there's
too much animal waste I think then runs
off and is not captured it runs off into
our rivers and streams and so nutrients
are sort of the driving list but also
climate change and my colleague at the
University of Regina Peter Leavitt he's
been doing sort of long-term ecological
research and monitoring lakes in the
Capel Valley for 27 odd years now but
for 11 of those year
every two weeks when there's no ice on
the lakes which is only for about six
months of the of the year in
Saskatchewan because it's pretty cold in
the winter for eleven of those years
they've been we've been collecting
microsystem concentrations so they've
been actually taking the water and
measuring how much of this toxin is in
each of them and if you're interested in
the things I'm about to show you this
paper just came out on Friday where you
can go and find out more about this sort
of stuff so the problem with microsystem
is we have these nan detects the micro
cysteine our method is for measuring the
toxin is not particularly sensitive to
very low concentrations and so when
there's only a few of these algae in the
water they they produce small amounts of
toxin and we maybe can't detect that so
we get a lot of observations that are
non detects or below our level of
detection so those data a censored we
know that they have a concentration that
is between zero and our level of
detection but we don't know what and the
true value is so ideally we'd like to
take account of that and we can't fit
these models in mg CV because mg CV
doesn't have any way any sense of
distributions mg CV doesn't have any
functionality for doing this but I
wanted to show this is what we we would
have for our for these data we've got
several lakes we've got quite a few legs
we've got six lakes that we're going to
do this modeling for I want to know how
the micro system concentration is
varying through the year and over time
because we're collecting every two weeks
so there's some increase over time in
the micro system concentration and then
a decrease at the end of the year but
that how are these things changing over
time so this is a tensor product it
gives us an interaction between these
two things and then I want to do this
separately for each Lake because each
loads gonna be showing different trends
over time because they're quite
different lakes in in some respects or
some of these lakes are anyway okay so
this would be if we had no sense of data
we could do this we just fit them
because then if this is a concentration
so it's a continuous value has to be
greater than zero and we would use a
gamma distribution with a log link but
the rest of this is sort of
similar to the things I've been showing
before if we do that we'd actually get a
bias model and we get an inconsistent
model because we're not taking into
account the values that we might treat
we might set all the sense of values to
have some half the detection limit or we
might just exclude those data and that
would give us a bias model and so using
brms we can fit essentially the same
model because it uses mgcp smooth but I
can also take account to the censoring
so this is the BRMS version of this
model
notice I said we had to use T to to get
tensor products so we're getting a
smooth this is the kind of this is the
smooth version of an interaction between
the day of year and the the time
variable the trend in our links okay but
we start this lip using t2 instead but
otherwise these two models are the same
thing and then on the left-hand side
here we just tell it which of our
observations are censored or not right
and then it fits a censored in this case
a sense of gamma model and then there
are some extra things because this is
doing hamiltonian Montecarlo we have to
tell it how many observations we want in
the warm-up and how many samples to do
how many chains and so on but they're
just sort of like the extra details just
like telling it that we wanted to use
method Remmel or what these control
parameters here from mgcp
so the nice thing is is that once you if
you know how to fit models an MD CV
it doesn't take that much to translate
that model into a fully Bayesian model
that you fit using VRMs
it takes a heck of a lot longer to fit
this model than it would in mgcp but
also this is the correct model and this
is is not the correct model
okay so doing the sampling takes a long
time but it's worth it especially in
this case so here I'm showing for the
are six lakes that we had these
concentrations for I'm just showing the
how well our model sort of does
relatively it fits the data pretty well
the red dots on here these are all the
censored values one of the advantages of
our model is and when there's the
censored observations we actually get a
fitted value so we have to we have to
set them to something when we put the
data into brms it doesn't actually use
this number we just set into our
detection limit
okay but we actually get a fitted value
for each of these on so we can actually
sort of do something with these we had
to get a model prediction for these
observations that we didn't know what
the microsystem concentration was Sloane
red and then the gray ones are all the
the detected microsystem concentrations
and for most of these to do a pretty
good job is roughly the sort of same
scatter above and below sometimes we are
actually on a look a little bit on the
low end we tend to under predict the
microsystem concentration but all in all
given that they're quite complicated
data we do a reasonable job of fitting
these things with our gams
so this is what the fitted with in yes
I'm showing here no the fits over day of
year this is the posterior mean of our
distribution and over time this is sort
of how things change within a year and
we can see that these lighter colors
represent later years so that does seem
to been some shift in both the shape at
these curves so we're seeing high
concentrations of micro sistine earlier
in the years and not all sites are doing
that with scanner had its highest
concentrations earlier in the record for
some reason this is the lake that's in
the centre of Regina and to some other
things but there is a general tendency
in most of the other sites to sort of
move so we're getting higher and mod and
detectable concentrations of microsystem
earlier in the year and I'll just do a
quick zoom in so you can sort of see
some of these things a bit more so we're
sort of seeing higher concentrations but
also we're seeing these peak
concentrations happening earlier in the
year okay so we can turn though that
information because we get the full
model posterior we can sort of say okay
I can predict what our model says for
every day of year for each of the years
in our time twos and I can say how often
out of all those posterior simulations
was did the model say that we were all
exceeding some drinking water qualities
so this is our detection level for the
micro system but then there are some
other drinking water water quality and
recreational thresholds for
concentrations of micro system and what
we're showing here then is the
probability for every day of the year
for each different year and we can see
Anne has just turned these numbers
essentially in
two probabilities of exceeding these
different thresholds and so we just zoom
in a little bit we see that we do see
much earlier we have a much higher risk
earlier in the season of detecting micro
system now and micro system
concentrations are very high for much
longer in the in the suggestion that you
have a much higher chance of being
exposed to this particular toxin for
much longer periods in the air and this
has implications if you know if you are
have a cottage on a lake and you which
many people do in the prairies and you
want to go swimming or you have pets who
you like going in the water this
potentially means that you can't
actually use the lake for as many days
of the year so yeah there's reduced
recreational efforts some of these legs
like Buffalo Pound is actually used as
the water source for Regina the city
here no they don't take the the water
from where the algae are living they
take it from deeper down but it does
there are implications for people who
are using other surface waters where
there are a little cargo concentrations
there those systems will also be showing
patterns like this they might be being
exposed to toxins in their drinking
water because of these changes in
essentially climate and nutrients over
the last few last decade and now because
it's a Bayesian model we want to see how
well do we recreate our data we have to
do some posterior predictive checks
these things can all be easily done from
the posterior and I'm showing several
different ones here but we actually
looked we didn't do I said we didn't do
a very good job we said of under
predicted at times but we also didn't do
a very good job of picking up the
proportion of non detects in our models
so our model actually the low end was
slightly over predicting so our models
are slightly conservative in terms of
the risk that you might have and but we
can do that for all sorts of different
concentrations and as soon as we start
to get a little bit of a higher
concentration there are purple
histograms here this is from every one
of our posterior drawers they start to
coincide with the observed values which
suggest that our generative model is
able to recreate most of the data it
just can't recreate quite so well
the number of non detects in here we
actually over predict those we actually
have so we're predicting lower than we
should be in terms of the micro system
concentration here were predicting too
many deter censored values but apart
from that our model does a pretty good
job okay if you're interested in how
these models work in more detail and
actually want to dig into some of the
code then these two papers this is a
paper that I wrote a couple years ago
which does the sort of things that I've
been talking about today but in lake
sediment records which are a bit more
complicated to fit things in but that's
got a ton of code in the supplementary
methods and then this paper with Eric
Peterson who is now at Concordia Dave
Miller who works in countries in the UK
and know'm Ross who I'm supposed to be
competing against today we wrote this
paper showing about how we do these
hierarchical models we fit more than one
site and there's a really good Kott
great collaboration we all four others
have taught and workshops together and
it was really good fun writing this
paper even though I think when we
started it we hadn't even met in person
before but there you can go and have a
look at those papers they're full of our
code if you want to know how we fitted
these models to those and I just like to
close them with some acknowledgments
funding sort of keep to my students and
me in money to do this work and also the
people who provided the data and
although I am i have got my slides they
will be up on my website here
unfortunately I made a bit of a get
error just before I came onto the zoom
meeting and so they aren't there but I
will make sure that they are there later
today after I figured out what my get
air is okay thank you very much
thank you very much wonderful talk I saw
some people saying how much it already
so thank you very much him if you were
in person we would give you a round of
applause if I was speaking at Ihram that
last week and they had virtual applause
machines ought to work on getting that
here for next time but thank you very
much for the wonderful talk my knowledge
of games has improved as I hope they
would so we have a few questions for you
let me dig in here let's see that a
recent one all right so I'm gonna try
and get an order that I've seen them so
bear with me as we go through them
someone has to question early beginning
is s predefined how would you derive how
would you derive s from that's sort of
cut off but how would you derive s and
what it has it defined so I guess
they're talking about the the function
in the in the models yeah I'll just go
and share my screen again might be
easier I'm yeah s is s is a function and
it can actually create lots of different
plots different splines the default is
the default is is to produce something
called a thin plate spline and I don't
want to get into too much of the detail
I want me to go back over here I don't
wanna get into much detail about it but
it is very similar to a cubic spline it
just has some extra properties that make
it optimal one of the reasons that the
either s that we have here is it uses
these fin plate splines is you have a
not selection problem so I mentioned
these knots that we that you have win
and you put a basis function at each
knot and so you have this problem if you
use cubic splines you have to tell it
how many knots you want and where you
want those knots and thin plate splines
allow you to get around that because
they you have a basis function at every
knot and and then Simon would came up
with this idea if that you could take
most of the information from this really
rich basis and get rid of
most of it and still keep most of the
information by using basically
essentially like a principal components
analysis on the basis just an eye candy
composition and so what you get by this
s right for default is not a cubic swine
it's a thin plate spine but you can
change the different splines and there
are lots of splines that are available
in in mg CV that include the cubic
splines and piece wines and B splines
but also more complicated things like
random effects and Markov random fields
and Gaussian processes and things and if
you want to know how they actually get
created then maybe talk to me afterwards
or you can have a look at Simon's book
where it explains a lot of this but
they're built in the same way I
essentially I showed you for the the
cubic splines it's just they're using a
slightly different equation than the
b-spline one then there's sorry the
Kiva's bottom one I'll say that I just
picked up picked up Simon's book I'll be
reading that soon and that my first
introduction is me go off on a tangent
here which is splines was from the h2
trips Yanni book their green book about
smooths and general nerves I think two
chapters on gams roughly or maybe one
chapter mm-hmm cool I mean one of the
things to be very careful of with with
that is a lot of people think about gems
in terms of what was in has been to be
on EES book and they have a package
called cam and that gets very confusing
and I see a lot of people get confused
trying to use tools from the GAM package
in M GCV and they're not working but
also vice versa and so if you are trying
some of this site don't load the cam
package and the energies to be packed at
the same time they can get caused
problems
yes great to know I find that a lot with
a hasty tribianni like for instance they
have the GBM package which has all of
them arguably been exceeded by XG boost
and they have the GAM package being
exceeded by mg CV they they pioneer the
field and someone comes and improves on
it very much so yeah they're off doing
other things and then it was just other
people picked up these ideas of doing
the actual smoothness selection and
that's what you'll get with ng CV yeah
wonderful
a little bit that history thank you we
have another question which probably not
necessary rally and actually Romney
already answered it Romney spoke last
month someone asked about packages in
Python
way to go Alan for to do gams
so no Romney already answered about
pygame and h2o do you have anything to
add to that
nope icons the one that I'm sort of at
least familiar with because I see people
asking questions about that I'm cross
validated and things I don't I don't
know pilot Python at all yeah cool well
well think Rami for that another
question is what do the beta
coefficients and the point at which one
changes from one spline to another
tell us about the physical properties of
the system tell us anything about the
system at all I mean they're essentially
they're they're not arbitrary but we we
just one thing I didn't cover in here is
I just said oh we have some basis
functions and by default that they're 10
they're not quite ten actually there's
but that's just a go with 10 there's 10
of these basis functions by default but
that doesn't mean that every system has
to have 10 basis functions when we're
fitting usually what we say is you need
to have as many basis functions as cover
the sort of explore the the complexity
that you expect so if your data are
wiggling all over the place then you
need more basis functions to fit so you
should choose that upfront and that the
defaults are essentially arbitrary and
but they don't really tell us anything
that we can't interpret those basis
functions and mechanistically and so
there might be some models like pharmo
for logical models where you fit a
particular function and the parameters
mean something with them most of the
models that we have here the parameters
are not interpretable in that kind of
way and so we don't mean anything
are there attributable in charitable
coefficients you get coefficients yeah I
mean essentially if we didn't have that
penalty in the model I'm doing the
penalized version of the model when
essentially agam is just the GLM it's
just no you've got many more columns in
your model matrix want their basis
function rather than a single value of x
so yeah the GAM is
if for a lot of cases is just the GLM
with an enriched model matrix so they
would mean as much as they would mean
for a linear model or a GLM it's just
that you can't even really interpret
them in necessarily in terms of the
underlying functions the splines because
they've often been subjected to this
eigen decomposition to make them to the
lower dimensional so they don't have an
ease then they're not into either
interpretable is the the main thing and
that's not why we're doing it we're more
interested when we're fitting these
models to estimate some change or
estimate some smooth relationship so
we're looking trees in the bigger
picture rather than what the individual
functions tell us and speaking of the
basis functions could you get similar
results from using the the basis spline
function I forget what it's called I
think it's ns
to create the new columns and fitting a
GL m on that would that give you a
similar answer if you were doing that
and if you use NS or BS they would get
very similar things the only difference
between there is that those things are
just fitting a regression spline there's
no penalty so you tell BS that you want
ten basis functions if you set the
degrees of freedom to be ten or
something then that's what you get and
there's no there's no shrinkage there's
none of this smoothness selection if you
use gloom net as your a regression model
would that get you closer then okay so
that would be yeah that would get you
closer because you're then shrinking the
parameters but the shrinking those
parameters in terms of the fit rather
than shrinking them in terms of the
curvature so that it's a different
penalty the penalties on the I guess the
absolute size of those coefficients as
opposed to the wig leanness of those
coefficients but actually that idea of
gloom net has been picked up and these
last few penalties as we picked up on a
very similar technique called the trend
filtering which that one of the tips
your honors I think it's actually Rob to
be honest son Brian as I've been working
on recently and trend filtering is is a
really interesting way of working with
splines has different properties
different penalties but that's where
such essentially applying the last sue
and a similar kind of way to fit these
splines on the coefficients not on the
curvature so well is actually your
curvature penalty looks like BAE
beta s beta and the Verger the ridge
penalty is essentially Beta Beta Beta
right so these are bridge penalties on
essentially I think they're [ __ ]
penalties as well no that's not true
some of the splines have bridge
penalties on them but yeah um it's um
actually asked about that the the s in
the beta transpose s beta is that
related to the s function or is that
another matrix in there no it's just the
SIS the terminology if Simon would the
penalty matrix that's where that's the
bit that encodes the information about
the week so something about the we
cleanest of the curve so I guess
weakness of the basis functions it can
encodes and it just means we make that
transformation so that when we're doing
our model estimating our model the
penalty is written in terms of the
coefficients is not written in terms of
something else that we have to calculate
just make simpler to fit yeah and
speaking of a guess explanation of it
someone asks what kind of language do
you use to explain gams and scientific
publications yeah I guess it depends who
were writing for so I Trent I try to not
use too much math I mean I'm not a math
geek at all I don't I don't always I
don't fully understand all of the math
behind these games and I just try and
explain them in terms of what they're
the smoothes actually represent so I
might talk about rather than like a the
smooth if you're the smooth of Dave yeah
I might be talking about how things
change with the seasonally or what the
long-term trend is and that's how I try
and explain these things and I'm more
interested in so we don't we're not
actually worrying too much about the the
individual basis functions it's more
just looking at the earthís splines that
we get out and then interpreting what
they mean so just telling us where
things have changed or what have you in
terms of trends okay so it's more about
in you know trying to interpret
individual variables necessarily well
you are yeah you can't you can do it but
you don't you often do it visually and
this is where I get back to the
sort of interpretation their model you
actually do the lot of the
interpretation visually in terms of the
effects so it's why I showed a lot of
plots and just so that we could see well
what was happening the splines were sort
of that microsystem removing earlier in
the year we can do things like compute
the derivatives so how how fast the the
slope is changing and that would allow
us to detect if there are changes so one
of the things we're doing with the
global temperature data is sort of
saying well where where can we detect a
significant change in that global
temperature and I don't know if you
remember a few years back there was this
big lot of the climate skeptics were
sort of saying oh that the climate is
that climate change is paused it was
there's a great pause thing going on
actually if you have you did fit those
data properly using one of these splines
the trend was always going up in their
shoes just they cherry pick the data and
weren't looking at it properly but we
can do things I don't actually look at
the derivatives of those curves and and
do stuff like that to get rid of rates
of change anything
speaking of visualization and
derivatives a leading question do you
know the good package for visualizing
this in you know are yes I mean not
quite a few people have come up with
packages for helping it sort of do more
things weekends so some of the packages
like en means for example and that has
functionality for working with jams one
of Simon Welker Simon was current
postdoc Mateo F SEO Allah has a package
called NGC vis which is on cran and
that's got a whole load of the data
visualization tools for working with
jams and then I have I've been working
on a package called gratia which is also
on crime making it easier to work with
make it easier to work with these empty
CD fitted models but using sort of Tidy
tools and returning tables and things
that you can plot with ggplot and stuff
like that I leaned questions I actually
had to have known tell me about that
package here recently and it was very
helpful oh thank you yep I gave a talk
about model visualization and that was a
nice one to have so thank you for
writing it sorry for the noise
he's very excited he's gonna regret this
in his life when he sees a video of
himself in front of a thousand people
he's squirming away we had another
question here we have a few questions
you you talked about actually a little
bit ago but someone did actually ask a
question the the 10 basis basis function
is by default is that a parameter you
would tune over or is this something
that the model sort of fits yeah so the
model RC does that internally so it's
not internally doing that optimization
so it's so I'm I'll probably get the
exact detail the I'll give them wrong
but essentially you have a value for the
smoothness parameter and then given that
value for this munis parameter you
choose some coefficients and then you
update your value of this Mira's
parameter that's all going on internally
in mg CV the only can the the only
problem with that is that you can only
fit as Wiggly a model as the number of
basis functions that you have and so if
you choose to view basis functions you
don't have enough then you might
understand you might end up fitting back
a straight line and so the main thing
that users have to do is they really
have to just choose this one thing it's
called K is the parameter it's not even
a parameter is just a number and that
just tells it how many basis functions
you want to use and I mean it sounds
easy but we just tell people I will just
choose set K large enough that it will
contain the sorts of wig leanness that
you want and but you do get uses as you
start fitting more models there is a
function in energy CV that will tell you
or guide you if that K was too low and
it's called gamma check and if you run
that on your model it will do a sort of
permutation test to see if there's any
any other wiggliness left in the model
it's writing the data in the residuals
and if there is that might suggest that
you need to put K higher and that's the
only thing that you really need to do as
a user beyond choosing which splines you
want to use and you just need to change
K yeah okay I guess I sort of thing you
could I know max is incorporating gams
into tidy models soon that could be a
variable you would just iterate over and
do again and again
you cut the
although a lot of the what what max is
doing in those models is essentially
like like the last penalty order you
want to know over that parameter well
yeah that's actually happening in the
model the problem is is that it can it
starts off with a value or the maximum
wigglers you can have if you've set that
too low then you might be missing some
of those
oh it's a maximum within it okay yeah
all right that that's what I was hoping
it was but it didn't sound like it okay
perfect yes it's the maximum we cleanest
yeah great
that made that makes even better don't
eat it tuner it ourselves I love it one
that I love one you don't want it's all
more automatic there's a question about
how do you think about extrapolating
outside the observed range of so there's
a range of games I see this is a yeah
you can you can't do it I mean you have
to be a bit careful about extrapolating
with games and certainly you you can't
just use the formulations that I had in
the slides here to do it because whilst
the extrapolation behavior might be
reasonable it'll just extract linearly
in some cases the uncertainty that you
get the bit model will say the
uncertainty on the estimate is way too
low it doesn't really reflect the true
in certainty and if you're using the
second derivative penalty then your
curves like these curves can actually
just go off all over the place so
they're really habla Matic so you have
to do some tuning and on my blog on my
website I had a post up like a couple of
weeks ago I'm just looking at how you
control some of the behavior for
extrapolating sort of briefly and and
there are ways that you can control it
and make it not do such silly things but
I think really that's not the main
advantage of of gams there because
they're really defined for the data
you're learning from the data that you
have and they're not really designed
then to sort of do some extrapolation
but you can do it you just be very very
careful
so speaking of extrapolating towards the
outside and you did say it's possible
but someone's asking about time
predictions of gams and does it how does
it diverge at the end there yeah
so depending on what kind of penalty you
use what kind of mix of penalties and I
would not fit the models that I was
doing if I if I wanted to predict like
four in the global temperature models or
whatever I wouldn't be using those those
particular splines I'd be using the B
spline version that comes of mg CV and
then what people are still working on
this and Dave Miller and Simon would are
actually doing some work on this they
were telling me recently but what you
want to do is you want you have your
penalty working out in that area where
you don't have so the that you use the
penalty to stop the curve going off and
doing really crazy things so normally
the penalty and the basis would be
defined just for your data but if you
can make the penalty extend whether both
ends or just one end if you want into
that period where you want to do your
prediction from if you make the penalty
go in there then it stops the curves
doing crazy stuff but it also allows the
uncertainty bands to more realistically
represent the the real uncertainty that
you have they'll still sort of
extrapolate off linearly right there
they just won't build it won't go crazy
but at least the uncertainty bands sort
of should go quite wide quite quickly
which is what we want and they don't if
you don't put the penalty out there is
that what a profit is doing so I'm not
100% sure exactly what profit is doing
and one of the other thing is if you've
got highly structured data like a no
profit is looking with sort of data that
are at a weekly level and you have daily
data and so you you would want to encode
a lot of that fluctuations and that
variation you'd want to encode that
using separates moods like I did in the
micro system where I had a smoother day
of year I didn't have just one really
complicated smooth that was going up and
down for every year over the thing and
when you do that you're not really
extrapolating for any of the I'm not
extrapolating for the day of year what
you're doing with profit is then you're
extrapolating just the year smooth and
that year smooth is probably a lot
simpler and it's probably just going to
sort of go off linearly into the future
and so I don't know profit that well I
had a brief look at the paper when it
when it came right
but I suspect that's what it's doing and
that's why you can extrapolate because
it's just sort of giving this maybe one
ahead prediction or something but you're
you're just predicting the next year and
everything else is not extrapolating
because you already have seen all those
days if you're all those holidays all
those days of weeks and you've learned
from the data what what those patterns
should look like and then then these
things work much better it looks like to
me it's a it's it's a like a Bayesian
gam but also it's like almost a bit like
the STL or a decomposes the seasonality
and the trend and does all that to speak
to your point yeah that's the main thing
there's Simon wooden in his book has an
example of by doing extrapolating from
the atmospheric co2 the Keeling curve
and it goes silly if you just have a
very weakly smooth getting all of the
seasonal variation as well as the trend
it does very silly things when you
extrapolate if you model the seasonal
variation with one smooth and then the
trend we were nervous move then it does
a really good job of extrapolating
outside if the range of the data and
that's when you doing gam you have like
a list of smoothes correct in you'd have
a list of smoothes if you fit in
multiple parameters and you in in the
back in the micro system one when I had
a tensor product or you you could have
just smooth of day view and a smooth of
your and then that would there be no
interaction but that's the decomposition
into a seasonal term and then the trend
but if you did that then the model would
be better behaved yeah when you're
extrapolating it seems like this
function has so many ways to configure
it ways to make the formulas or someone
to asked what is the title of simon's
book it's called I think generalized
additive models right yeah yeah there
you go generalized additive models an
introduction we bar make sure you get
the second edition I am NOT on retainer
it's a really good book it's it's in
this the red series room from CRC but
it's full of tons of our code as well
it's not just the math right and if you
you can skip the math bit
and do the practical bits and then go
back to the math bits if you interested
in Roy and how these things work there's
a really good book really recommended
just had to check our second issue
because I just got it so oh yeah you've
been missing out on a lot if you had the
first edition ah
good to know good - I get the recent one
I know this one's interesting what is
the best way to impose monotonicity in a
game so to do that you have to impose
some constraints on the coefficients and
you can't do that in mg CV I think that
part of the reason for that is it
doesn't quite fit within the sort of
fitting algorithms easily that Simon has
an mg CV but he had he's had a I think
she was a PhD student of his called
Natalia PR py a yeah and she has a
package called the scam the shape
constrained additive models and that can
do all kinds of shape can constraints on
the shape so you can enforce
monotonicity and things like that it
just doesn't I don't think you can do
smoothness selection with dremel and
things like that with it though he's
just using GCV smoothness selection
there are some things Simon has an
example in his book of using shape
constrained piece blinds but again
you're not choosing the smooth that you
have to guess the smoothness parameter
when you do that you can't get mgcp to
do it but scam will do this movement
selection for you if you use that and it
works in the same way as mg CV you just
there are different kinds of splines
that have different shape constraints on
there that's pretty cool
well do one or two more own leaks I know
we want to get to the virtual bar if you
we need to go to bed whatever it may be
nice what we got here uh hello this is
interesting in many of these examples
we're looking at one measurement at each
time point
how did games handle uncertainties when
there are multiple measurements at each
time point like with replica surveys
yeah that's where the hierarchical bit
comes in so in the same way that I had
multiple I mean as far as the model was
concerned when I had six likes I just
had a single response variable and then
we used the random spline to sort of
break them up you could do the same sort
of thing with replicates it would just
sort of innocence if he just had
replicas and he didn't do anything else
they were all just in the same time
point it would just try and fit the
average value at those those things if
you're talking about you measured the
same thing but in lots of different
places and so then you might want to do
like random effect type modeling within
mg severe and include random effects you
can certainly do all of that and the
models that I was showing and the paper
there Eric and Peterson and gnome and
Dave Miller and I wrote and so tries to
explain how you might fit those models
and the different kinds of models that
you can are the different ways you can
fit them in MVC V so you can handle that
if they're kind of thinking of technical
replicates then the model would just
sort of smooth through you've got three
replicates for each observation it would
just go through the average of those and
average in terms of whatever that on the
link scale it would be yeah okay good so
no hierarchical models are all the rage
right now let's see we have time for one
more so yeah when you sort of addressed
this but like how do we know the number
of knots in in the smooth function used
in again so I can ml n LM e you can
define the number of knots a polynomial
degree I think you're saying earlier not
to define that yeah well if you're gonna
choose the number of knots you have the
problem of then saying where should
those not speak as well and so if you if
you want to avoid that entirely I mean
really what I was just showing the
number of knots just controls the number
of basis functions and for most cases
isn't the the models are not that
sensitive to where you place the knots
all right so that's why the default in
MVC V if you have if you use that the
cubic splines the default is just two
set them up evenly spaced across the
range of the data know that if your data
irregularly spaced and you have lots of
data in certain regions you might want
to have more knots there than elsewhere
so you might want to control what but
the advantage of the the default basis
in in mg CB and the s function is this
VIN plate spline is that you don't have
to think about where those knot should
be in fact there is a knot at every data
point and then because that gives you a
really rich basis in fact it's too rich
it would slow down the computing
massively if we used all of those not
knots and spline basis functions what
Simon does easily truncates it and it
just concentrates the signal in that
basis into the first few eigenvalues and
then that's what we use right and so you
try to avoid if you don't want to choose
the number of knots and where those knot
should be just use the default basis and
the only thing you have to tell it then
is how many basis functions and that's
been through to this parameter argument
kay and that just sets them up a limit
on the Wigg leanness and you could be
really crazy and set K really high as
many as your data as many as the number
of data points minus one the penalty
will then shrink all of that back and
just use what's needed but you'll just
be wasting CPU cycles doing it but you
can do that the penalty will shrink all
of that extra wiggliness away if it's
not needed
yes yes or no I'm good to talk that you
know the linear model is essentially a
special case of this and it was not
needed out that's what would be selected
so why not put it in a smooth yeah yeah
I mean the only slight caveat on that
and you know we do say these things but
the theory of these models starts to
break down a little bit when you get
very close to that being Linney when
it's just slightly nonlinear and then
the models are very they're very the gun
is very difficult to choose between
something as linear as something that's
slightly curved and all the theory that
we have for correcting the uncertainties
for having chosen the smoothness
parameters and all the rest of that all
of that ai
see and everything starts to break down
a little bit just as that boundary yeah
but in there are ways to then say well
let's just fit the linear model let's
fit a model with a smooth in plus the
linear function and if that might that
smooth explains a little bit more then
we can go with the smooth version or you
just accept that you don't really know
whether something's exactly linear or
slightly curved just go with the smooth
model and apart from a little bit of
extra time in fitting the model you know
it's not usually that much more you
guard against choosing assuming that
things are linear when they're not yeah
and MDC via cam can do everything that
the GLM function can do so if you're
fitting a GL m there's no real reason
perhaps why you wouldn't necessarily
want to do smooth and also mgcp has got
a lot more families in it so you can fit
what a range of models now that you
can't do with GL m so there are lots of
advantages to using it I'm tweeting that
if you're gonna do a GLI meat just use
game instead I'm tagging you okay well
thank you so much for this wonderful
talk again if we were in person I'd give
you a big round of applause so thank you
very much
there's talk I would like to just make a
few announcements to everyone while
they're still here first of all actually
to you you answered one of the first
ever Stack Overflow questions I asked
like 10 years ago almost so thank you
for answering that and people are still
commenting on that question in fact
people will answer me with the solution
you gave because I incorporated that
into my book and their answer you answer
from my book and exciting it now looking
at who asked the question yep thank you
I'd like to thank eco Health Alliance
they provided this zum-zum not Zoom link
the zoom interface for us they've been
doing that for the past few months thank
you it's really I think known for that
he's the driving force behind getting
this from eco health alliance I think
you know minigolf Alliance but I also
like to thank one of our sponsors and we
talked about my piece I showed off
earlier
Scott's Pizza tours is offering
25% off their their virtual tours
through the end of July so if you'd like
to take a virtual Pizza tour and I've
been watching them there is I used to be
one of the real tour guides we gave
tours in person so now with the virtual
ones are pretty cool if you want to get
a 25% off it's nerds love pizza is the
discount code it's cots Pizza tours so
thank you to Scott for sponsoring us as
well
let me just make sure if I have any
other announcements I don't want to miss
them I keep a list of these things
remember next month will happily
announcing that soon remember that our
conference coming up August 12 through
15 that includes the workshops and there
is if you can't find the bar in the
gather map there is a link which Amato's
going to post if she hasn't already to
the event channel and you could post it
right here in this chat to please if
people like to go hang out in the
virtual bar I got myself a bottle of
gummy ano delivered with that pizza so
I'm gonna go enjoy that sparkling red
wine often called the pizza wine Gavin
we haven't really met me in person Noma
tell you I am more than obsessed of
pizza make a little unhealthy I know
it's very healthy my cholesterol has
gone downhill since I've eaten so much
and I hope everyone had a wonderful time
I know I did we will get the slides from
Gavin up on and my heck are very soon
stay tuned for more announcements in the
mailing list and we will be posting this
video on our YouTube channel within the
next few days so thank you everyone for
attending I hope to see you in the
virtual bar whether you want to have a
glass of water or soda or a beer or wine
whatever you want to do and once again I
know we can't applause for real but
thank you very much Gavin this has been
wonderful thank you very much thank you
hope to catch some of you in the bar in
a minute yes I'll be right there
good bye everyone